un rapide bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ce matin l'or vient de
voir le gouvernement afghan demande aux
puissances étrangères de ne plus
expulser de migrants temporairement face
à la menace permanente des talibans une
requête légitime selon vous oui tout à
fait d'autant plus comme peut pas
garantir que ce gouvernement reste en
place un moyen terme vu l'avancée des
talibans sur une partie importante du
pays que vous venez de montrer à l'écran
l'avancé de cette force et extrémiste
que constituent les talibans a par
ailleurs provoqué un certain chaos dans
le pays et il y aura sans doute des
réfugiés intérieurs et déplacés qui va
se réfugier d'une zone du pays vers une
autre les personnes qui se sont
particulièrement menacés par les
talibans ça peut être des minorités
religieuses chiite par exemple ça
peuvent être des femmes ça peuvent être
des des activistes de la cause sociale
par exemple dans les grandes villes
lien j'ai eu au téléphone un
syndicaliste qui à kaboul qui a indiqué
craindre au service si jamais les
talibans elle prenait sa vie par
ailleurs et indépendamment de l'avancée
des talibans qui elle est liée à
l'activité internationale et à la
décision de retrait du président joe
biden
il ya aussi un une grave crise qui a été
piqué par le courant d'un virus et kiko
faire tous les pays de la planète mais
qui est pauvre et désorganisée par
quarante ans de guerre différentes
phases assez différente mais 40 ans de
guerre pour différentes raisons et qui
frappent l'afghanistan plus durement que
d'autres pays qui peuvent ils faire face
au sein d'un système de santé structures
eas qui n'est pas le cas vous voir à
distance donc bosser deux facteurs on
comprend aisément que les autorités ne
sont pas en mesure d'accueillir des
nouvelles des nouvelles personnes
rapatriées
d'autant plus qu'il ya aussi des
personnes qui reviennent poussée de gré
ou de force de pays voisins dans la
région et notamment de l'iran lui même
en crise en raison des sanctions
américaines
alors certains ont commencé à fuir on
sait que
beaucoup d'entre eux sont arrivés en
turquie d'autres pourraient débarquer en
italie d'ailleurs mario draghi
s'inquiètent justement de cet afflux de
migrants
c'est le cas bien sûr il y aura des
migrants qui fuient spécifiquement les
talibans encore une fois des personnes
qui a plus à craindre que d'autres
sachant qu'il ya une migration une fuite
continue de l'afghanistan depuis
plusieurs années ça n'a pas commencé
aujourd'hui ce qui change à mon avis ce
qui changera c'est le profil des
personnes qui partent aujourd'hui ça
pourra être des personnes qui font plus
spécifiquement l'application du
programme idéologique des talibans hier
c'était peut-être plus des personnes qui
fuyaient les combats ou encore qui fuit
le fait qu'en s'accaparer de l'inter
parce qu'à l'analyse a tapé majoritaire
mari cole est un phénomène récurrent
c'est ce qui favorise et par la vie par
les violences multiples petits qui
existent dans le pays
le fait qu'en prennent les terres des
personnes qui en vivent
par exemple pour y planter de l'opium
pas uniquement mais des grands
propriétaires s'accaparent des phases et
des terres c'est en partie peau et
cultiver la drogue
et donc c'était plutôt ça le profil des
personnes qui est contrainte au départ
le niveau général des violences
le fait de priver des gens de la
ressource de vicky qui a été favorisée
facilitées par cette violence demain ça
peut changer le profil et ça sera plutôt
des personnes mais qui en raison des
caractéristiques personnelles ont tout à
craindre des talibans donc à mon avis ce
n'est pas le fait qu'ils aient les
accords qui se déplacent qui va changer
baisser les groupes qui vont d'abord
fuir le pays alors pour éviter que le
pays ne sombre dans une crise
humanitaire est ce qu'aujourd'hui la
solution doit être politique avant tout
bien entendu dans un pays encore une
fois pour ou poids des facteurs diverses
il ne se confondent pas qui est en
conflit armé depuis maintenant plus de
40 ans et puis
la deuxième moitié des années 1970
d'abord pour des raisons intérieures et
puis il ya des puissances qui multiplie
aussi qui s'est emmêlé et à ne pas
oublier nos voisins pakistan qui est un
puissant soutien aux talibans évidemment
dans un pays où les conflits seraient
les coucheries multi fort se règle par
la violence elle aussi multiforme
il faut les remplacer la violence
militaire et brut par la politique
il faudrait surtout que le pakistan ce
l'appareil sécuritaire et militaire et
pakistan cesse de soutenir et de porter
à bout de bras les talibans qui nous
fait comme ils l'ont fait ce qui fait ce
qui ferait déjà cessé l'avancée
fulgurante des talibans comme un jeu ce
n'est pas l'unique facteur mais c'est un
facteur très important est évidemment 20
ans d'occupation qui encore qui a
commencé en 2001 ont montré que ce n'est
pas par l'emploi de la force militaire
en réseau le problème parce que il
s'agissait à partir de là tu as qui a
commencé le 7 octobre 2001 puis la prise
de kaboul qui a qui a été fait
13 décembre 2001 il s'agissait de
chasser les talibans du pouvoir les
talibans aussi fort et un pan t'es
qu'une qu'il l'était à l'époque
donc on a bien vu que l'emploi de la
force militaire ne résout pas le
problème
l'urss à l'époque l'avait aussi appris à
ces départs mais pour d'autres facteurs
et aussi avec un puissant soutien des
états unis à l'époque forces
fondamentalistes islamistes merci
beaucoup en tout cas maintenant tu fait
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes avocat au barreau
de paris et spécialiste du droit des
étrangers